now we're going to take you to Turkey
where catastrophe has turned into a
humanitarian crisis for survivors of
last week's earthquakes amazingly there
are still people being pulled alive from
this Rubble like the 17 year old teenage
boy but as MTS tayab shows us many
survivors are now living in tents and
they're in the freezing cold
at night when the temperature plunges to
Sub-Zero the only way to keep warm is by
burning wood scavenge from nearby houses
destroyed in the Quake families once
prosperous now live in these donated
tents set up at a local park a once
happy place now one of misery and deep
uncertainty
it's here we meet engineering student
Abdul Rahman and his family they are
Syrian refugees from Aleppo displaced by
the war and now homeless once again what
will you do now you have no home
everything's destroyed
we will leave this city and start over
again he says we'll be fine we're used
to a hard life but few others here are
across turkey are hundreds of makeshift
camps like this and while Aid is
available with every passing day
conditions are only worsening as trash
piles up because there's no one to
collect it
in Hattie's Old City a once thriving and
ancient quarter it's now unrecognizable
and unlivable
the Turkish government has promised it
will rebuild all damaged buildings
across the country within a year
but few here believe that and have other
pressing concerns like burying the Dead
all too often in Mass Graves like bees
off the side of a highway the makeshift
graves are as far as the eye can see and
they're digging even more
the U.N estimates the number of dead
could pass over 50 000 but with the
remains of so many buried under
mountains of rubble we may never know
the true number of those who died for
CBS mornings I'm India's turkey
[Music]